una carrera de última hora los
supermercados en la capital de china los
residentes de beijing se abastecieron de
alimentos impulsados por los temores de
un cierre total de la ciudad a medida
que aumentan los casos de kobe 19 los
compradores dejaron los estantes vacíos
temerosos de la escasez de alimentos
como la registrada en shanghai
no pensamos en que comprar solo espero
que no sea como un chándal
tememos que si se cortan los envíos los
suministros no cubrirán nuestra demanda
las autoridades de la ciudad dicen que
garantizarán el suministro estable de
necesidades básicas luego del brote en
el área beijing se puso en alerta
después de que se registraran 70 nuevos
casos de covite desde el viernes casi
dos tercios de los nuevos casos
provienen del distrito de chaoyang en el
centro de la ciudad las autoridades
ordenaron a los 3.5 millones de
residentes a realizarse tres pruebas pcr
durante los próximos cinco días
estoy preocupada especialmente porque
trabajo en el distrito de chaoyang así
que me preocupa que suceda algo aquí
nadie quiere estar en esta situación si
está bloqueado es por el bien de todos y
eso puede poner fin a la epidemia
las autoridades sanitarias chinas
esperan evitar que se repitan los
acontecimientos de shanghai que ha
estado bajo estricto confinamiento
durante casi cinco semanas sus
residentes han tenido problemas para
acceder a alimentos y suministros
esenciales lo que ha causado frustración
los números de beijing son bajos en
comparación con los estándares globales
pero china sigue comprometida con su
estricta estrategia cero covite